I finally have
might be above the Fiat mysteries
come on guys got some Betterton
we should drink some time so much fun
together Suicide Squad rated pg-13
hey youtubers its charlie we should get
drinks together sometime so you know
video a little bit different today not
seeing my face just because there's some
technical issues going on in my
apartment but a whole bunch of Suicide
Squad stuff happening just basically
telling you to shut up and take my money
on Friday so they're just selling
advance tickets the movies out in August
of course they're gonna bring a whole
bunch of stuff to comic-con but what
they're talking about today like the new
stuff I know I just posted a Suicide
Squad video but the really cool thing is
it just like people got to go to the set
of Justice League people got invited to
the set of Suicide Squad
so like DC is opening up the back lot
for them to come check everything out
margot robbie was talking all about
harley quinn and it is absolutely
fascinating what she said about Jared
Leto on set so she said going into the
movie she was like I heard that he was a
method actor and he's playing the Joker
and he's like the craziest person ever
so she was wondering to herself is she
gonna get beat up on to because she's
not method so if you don't know what
method acting is like you hear about
certain actors being really intense on
set getting into character Daniel
day-lewis is probably the most famous
one who's working today where in order
to find their character an actor will
basically live as that character think
as them just try to construct this
reality around them that supports that
idea so everybody on set has to call
them by their character's name when
they're interacting with people outside
of scenes they also stay in character so
like you know when cameras roll actors
get into character you know you're
playing a super here you're playing
Superman you're playing Batman then
Affleck will become Bruce Wayne but when
the director says cut he'll become Ben
Affleck again like his children could
come say hello to him like hey Dad you
know this is so cool that you're playing
Batman but where he a method actor and
his kids came to visit him they would be
visiting Bruce Wayne it's just a way for
people to deliver more authentic
performance but it's so intense it's so
hard on you psychologically that most
actors choose not to do it especially if
you're working in TV and you shoot like
a hundred and eighty Days a year most of
the time when you hear about method
actors they're really movie actors
because they tend to be on set like they
tend to actually be filming for shorter
periods of time so it's easier to
construct this alternate persona and
just completely be that person for that
short period of time than it is for say
someone on like the DC TV shows like
someone asks Stephen Amell like are you
mad he's like no absolutely not there's
no way I would be able to
be a human being and still be a method
actor so if you've heard the stories
about Jared Leto doing crazy things with
the other actors on set sending them
really perverted stuff in the mail just
really like the nastiest stuff ever the
funniest reaction from his cast mates
not like most of the people inside the
Suicide Squad like Margot Robbie as
Harley Quinn she's like okay I get it I
understand you need to do this we need
to sell this codependent chaotic
relationship between these two
characters so she's totally down for it
but one of the few people who just
absolutely was not down for his [ __ ]
just was not having it at all was Viola
Davis as Amanda Waller she was
absolutely pissed I mean not like Amanda
Waller doesn't share a lot of scenes
with the Joker but the thing is is that
like he would actually mess with the
other actors even when they weren't in
scenes together so you kind of have to
imagine the actual Joker being on a
movie set in real life like what would
the Joker be like if he were on a TV
show or a movie which is funny they
actually did that on the animated series
where like the Joker takes over the
airwaves during a Christmas broadcast
but that was Mark Hamill's version of
the Joker and it was a little sweeter
because it was a children's cartoon but
the way Margot Robbie talked about her
relationship with the Joker Harley
Quinn's relationship with the Joker
isn't that like she also thrives on
chaos and the way that he does and
that's part of what seduces her because
when she's still dr. Harleen Quinzel
treating him in arkham she's seduced to
the dark side of the force like he
brings out that chaotic side of her like
if you were to imagine within all of us
there's that chaotic person and the
Joker just kind of pulls at that thread
and she finds it very attractive so
that's what makes her fall in love with
him then we get to see her
transformation and flashbacks he
basically puts her through the same
process that he went through and that's
how her skin goes white also a little
bit of electroshock therapy in there but
they did confirm that those were
flashbacks so it's not gonna be like a
linear origin story for her character
the fun twist of the movie I think will
be watching her bond with her new
teammates when they find out they were
picked because they were expendable
so the real story of the movie isn't so
much about them chasing down tattoo man
or like this other mystical threat in
Midway City it's really the story of how
they come together how some of their
worst qualities become their best
qualities that they all share together
and what's going to be happening when
the Joker comes and tries to bring her
back like you should be with me
now with your friends you have to
imagine like a really toxic boyfriend
who is so needy and codependent that he
can't stand it that she has other
friends that she likes just as much as
him so I'm thinking part of Harley
Quinn's arc is just realizing that she
doesn't necessarily need the Joker even
though she's probably still going to be
obsessed with him and don't forget they
might talk about this at comic-con
I'm not expecting too much news about it
but they are planning more Harley Quinn
like Gotham City sirens type movie like
a female team-up spin-off movie with
Harley Quinn in the lead as for more
direct sequels to this movie I
definitely think they're gonna make more
Suicide Squad movies but what they'll
probably do and they do this in the
comics all the time is that they'll just
rotate the members of the Suicide Squad
so they'll swap actors in the swap
actors out it's a big cast so don't be
surprised if one of the Suicide Squad
people gets killed off leaving room for
a new one to come in in the next movie
but as for the presence of Batman so we
all know what Batman's doing in Suicide
Squad the funny thing is as a David Ayer
was asked why did you choose Batman to
be in the movie that's like a you know
pretty big Pig and his answer was like
well it had nothing to do with like the
DC extended movie universe it was just
because I really wanted Batman in the
film and Warner Brothers was like okay
yeah you can totally use Batman so Ben
Affleck had to sign on you know it
required some contractual stuff but
logically when he was thinking about the
movie and thinking about putting Batman
in the reason was because Batman so just
funny because you know spoiler alert
everybody wants Batman to be in their DC
Comics property even if it's the TV
shows so Batman is awesome and that is
why he is in the movie so just be
thinking about that in the back of your
mind I'm not expecting them to announce
anything specific anytime soon because
they're still working on Justice League
that's like their main focus getting
that done now getting Suicide Squad out
getting ro and hype up about that so
tickets are on sale on Friday the movie
isn't out to August and then in about
two weeks we'll have Comic Con so when
we get a little closer I'll do some more
Suicide Squad Justice League Comic Con
stuff so be sure to subscribe to get
that and congratulations to this week's
giveaway winner Triforce P you win a $20
Amazon gift card just be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details that's
just on the about page so they'll be
more DC more Marvel this week but
tonight I'm gonna do a mr. robot season
2 video there's a bunch of footage of
this out I'll talk about what happened
during season 1 and if you guys really
want I will do season 2 videos so just
look out for that video later tonight
while you guys wait for me to post that
you can click up here on the top link
for my last Suicide Squad video and you
can click down here on the bottom one
for my flash season 3 video thank you so
much for watching everybody you know
phantom high fives from behind the
screen I'll see you guys tonight